all right good afternoon everyone
did I did I get a response back good
afternoon everyone all right
yeah who's enjoy their niche near its
experience so far this week oh come on
you guys can do better than that who's
enjoying Europe's 2018 here in Montreal
that is more like it well on this final
workshop day hello i'm kenny chen i'm
from a sender over in Pittsburgh and I'm
proud to be one of the organizing
members of the AI for social good
workshop that you're here with us for
today and we have a really exciting
special program for you on the on the
impact of AI and arts music and culture
as well as vice versa because it is you
know not a unidirectional relationship
there and so the the next hour will be
composed of a demonstrate well
unfortunately this was meant to be a
demonstration of an emotive EEG headset
on on yo-yo Ma's head while he plays
music and doing live neuro informatics
but unfortunately Olivier Olivier from
who's the president of emotive had his
visa blocked and he's stuck in Las Vegas
for the time being so we were able to
bring a last-minute but very qualified
pinch-hitter Douglas egg from Google
brain who is also the founder of magenta
as well as the Brahms Center at the
University of Montreal you can also look
forward to presentations from Karina
Kessler Wong from kisser wanna toe and
Valerie Beckett from element AI they
will each give ten minute presentations
before all four of them engage in a
panel discussion at the very end there
will be hopefully some time for
questions and I would just like to give
a big shout out and thank you to element
AI who sponsored this lunch and the you
know the the ones that we were able to
distribute them I'm afraid we weren't
able to feed everyone but be fed don't
pass out we don't want to deal with
anybody's so anyway without further ado
it is my tremendous pleasure to
introduce shell world-renowned cellist
and a personal inspiration and hero of
mine
yo-yo ma
[Applause]
[Music]
Vallely
henna Douglas okay that's it
good morning you wanna say something
good afternoon okay I don't know what's
happening but I'm gonna start doing one
thing to start this off and how's that
as you know I'm sort of like the joke
here because this is a show-and-tell and
and they need a token musician to do
something I'm a token in more than one
way subway token being one so I'm gonna
play something for you that let's say is
written down it's about 300 years old
and you can get the music you could do
the same thing and it's pretty much
always the same and I'm going to play it
without interpretation because my friend
here Douglas is very interested in what
does a person interpreting something do
to something that's written down and
this may have something to do with what
my colleagues Kareena and and vanity are
going to talk about also in their work
so here's 20 seconds of something
[Music]
so this is something that you might get
if you go to a you know a you know a
fifty dollar synthesizer to say I'm
going to plug this in and I'm gonna get
these notes now I'm gonna add one thing
and it's not actually necessarily a
musical thing but it's just one idea and
I'd like you to tell me what the
difference is and then Douglas will also
show us something that we need to figure
out so that one thing is what you all
know because you're humans you know the
feeling of gravity right so you know you
can only jump so high you know that
you're pulled down that you know in
another 20 years like me you'll be about
an inch shorter that's called long-term
gravity now in terms of short term
gravity how does gravity affect if I say
plug in gravity into this piece of music
that you just heard let's see what it
sounds like
[Music]
what's different anybody I went deeper
as it basically I was actually feeling
dragged down by whenever I was going
towards low if if you go low
I go lower anybody else yeah
acceleration yes sometimes the force of
gravity is pulling me down faster right
anybody else very good yep
what base notes yeah headed towards base
notes great Douglas
yes this work dear friend yes would you
play us something if I could hold the
cello no sure stroke
okay okay so I wanted there to be some a
conversation with yo-yo so I'm going to
play a piece of AI generated music it's
always good to follow something like
that slightly intimidating but I got a
type of type of password here he's gonna
create it right now
Douglas ech mr. genius okay
so this work was done by a number of
people who are not me including Anna
Hong and Ian Simon and Adam Roberts and
Jessie angle so what you're gonna hear
is some combination and for those of you
that are in the machine learning world
which is most of you some combination of
transformer and wavenet and it's a piece
of music built and performed by a neural
network and I'm hoping to get some some
feedback from yo-yo on how good and or
bad it is and I'm not setting it up to
be great so let's hope the audio works
we did not do a sound check you are
offline
some functionality I think I'm joking
okay okay I'm gonna pause it can can we
bring up the sound a little bit do we
have a sound can you'll bring it up okay
I'll start it over we'll need to be a
little bit louder
[Music]
beautiful this is this is the
culmination of my career so far so
different
so notice Douglas did it look ma no
hands that's amazing
do you have dove oh no I would like to
ask vanity you used to play cello and
you listen to this piece what do you
think of it what's your response
Luke's piece yeah what I think of it um
well I I'm gonna I'm gonna say the same
thing that you said to us like just just
behind thinking about the people behind
the you are being the cello who are the
people behind the the algorithm are the
musicians how the what kind of data did
they use are they interprets like you
are do you think well I think definitely
you could tell from some of the chord
progressions that this person well first
of all is a pianist or whoever is is is
creating the algorithm knows piano
playing is probably a classical pianist
but is interested in jazz
this is true right Ana asana and because
you could hear that in the progressions
and and and she's obvious now I know it
says she but it's it's a person who who
knows a number of different styles so I
suspect that she knows twelve-tone music
or she knows her Sharon Burke she
probably knows some Debussy is Ana out
here somewhere I'm not sure because this
was announced late oh well yeah so you
know we'll never know but but the point
is actually and where this may have
something to do with our discussion I
feel that actually my job we were asking
each other what was the thing that you
wanted a sentence that you would say to
describe what you care most about what
you do and I think if I had to describe
what I'm always interested in is to
figure out who did it and why in
anything so so it's for me it's really
interesting to hear a piece of music
whether it's you know machine learning
deep learning or a person well I want to
know the combination thereof created and
why was it done
to prove something was it done for fun
was it done for just understanding or
was it done to exploit something you
know are you selling a piano no I don't
think so
are you trying to you know but but I
would ask those questions and and and
those you know does that make sense to
you absolutely you know as as a manager
the main I think the main important
thing is to think about the individuals
that are behind the code behind the
instrument so it makes absolutely sense
and
keine I asked you what you were thinking
about when you were 15 and she said I
was interested in everything everything
philosophy you know she's you have many
many different backgrounds in cultural
backgrounds in your in your history and
therefore I think her your answer to
what you care about most is to really
make sure that that all voices have you
know equity essentially so least heard
voices actually also have some form of
representation but so tell me what what
you whether so what are the problems
that you are dealing with most these
days
besides life balance and I think it's
assumed see also said before that you're
trying to understand why people do
things and what it wasn't in scale
between understanding and exploiting and
I think that is something that I do
focus a lot my work on on trying to
understand and trying to accompany
communities and companies who are trying
to understand without going too far on
the exploiting side because it's
important to integrate all the voices
but not to steal the voices but to
amplify the voices and and how do you
since you're mr. Google brain right yeah
there's for some definition of mister
okay he's a hue hue person at training
what so what so I mean how do you do the
proportion between your interests of
what you were doing with Brahms and
other before you became before you went
to Google think magenta whatever right
it's a call okay you know so could you
tell me how do so working for a very
large entity versus doing research how
does that how do you how did you does
your mind change does it affect your
actions or your thinking that's funny
isn't it I've tried not to that the
jokes in my head are cascading yes
seriously I think at least for me you
know I was at University of Montreal for
many years and loved it and I think I've
honestly never cared about career
success I've just always been trying to
do what I love and at the time point in
time when I did a dissertation and
nonlinear dynamics and musica rhythm I
should have just entitled the
dissertation career suicide : you know a
you know because you know how are you
ever gonna get a job doing that and you
know I think just uh it's good to follow
your passion and that's that's what I've
done and I think that University of
Montreal has supported that wonderfully
and to be to be really fair Google has
supported it wonderfully too and been
able to just kind of keep trying to push
the envelope a little bit about what we
can do in the space of machine learning
and music well I know that there's a lot
a lot large part of this conference is
thinking a lot about the the
relationship between you know cultural
activities and nai and and I know you
you're very optimistic about what that
could bring to the field of the
expressive arts
in terms of right now so would you like
to comment with anyone if you like to
comment on this I think you know I
called it collisions before color you
know the two worlds colliding research
and an art I think it's it's it's
important and it's so wonderful that
there's so many people and I hope that
they're not here only to hear you but to
hear about AI and aren't let's hope and
so I'm pretty pretty optimistic about
that it's it's becoming like a tool the
new cello is is just there you know in
the on the laptop the new the new artist
the young artists they are starting
maybe with with code so what will happen
with that it's wonderful
got it would you'd like to either
responders so I'm not an artist and I'm
not a scientist
and I don't work in AI so the
perspective from which I I come here is
wondering if indigenous voices can help
yeah I can and to develop and what role
I do this voices can really play and a
lot of the time when people think about
indigenous storytelling they think about
an interest or telling in the past but
indigenous languages and culture have so
much to tell about our future so how do
we make sure that the people who are at
Google and what element AI they are
diversified and they bring different
perspectives and they aren't just
scientists but also artists and also
linguists and also social workers so
that you know we can build AI that as
the conference called here is for social
good
yeah I'm that's a massive challenge and
one that I think probably everybody in
the room can but maybe not everybody but
can reflect and realize that we still
have a tremendous amount of work to do
to move to move in that direction even
thinking about the work you know that
we're doing in the space of machine
learning in the arts you know consider
where where the datasets are consider
that how much western music dominates
the data that we train on probably once
every 18 months someone comes to talk to
me about some form of music from outside
of my world maybe it's Indian music and
the answer is always shrug shoulders
whereas the data and so you know I think
we if if this data is a mirror of
ourselves and and and machine learning
is a is in some ways providing us this
very interesting mirror of our world we
obviously need to take great care to
actually pay attention to the whole
world can I say something kind of maybe
silly to all of you I I used to think
that I used to hope like maybe ten years
ago that culture should have a seat at
the table of economics and politics now
I thought gee that's nice you have a
Venn diagram and you have that little
spot in the middle where good things can
happen but I've since maybe modified
that thinking slightly because I now
think that culture actually is the table
from which economic and political
development can happen
why because I think that everything that
we do in this room is invented you know
we make a difference but you know
there's art with this culture there's AI
there's you know there's tech actually
we invented all this stuff and and the
question is back to who and why you know
why did we invent this I think I think
we invented all of this because these
invention
serve to give us a leg up in through
understanding in terms of dealing with
the world and surviving so all of this I
think is designed to help us survive we
talked about service right in the phone
call a couple days ago and think about
that why are we doing all this and
aren't we not actually thinking about
for the really for the first time mutual
survival so instead of nation-building
which we could do very well at various
times we now actually have issues that
deal with all of a sudden so in a way
instead of seeing what we do as a threat
which can be and we should think about
that very much so but actually and
without trying to be you know sort of
you know rose-colored glasses now we are
trying to survive we are in the
Anthropocene era and and we actually
need all hands on deck to help that's my
sense from talking to my millennial
friends that that you know these are
these are issues that you care a lot
about and maybe people my old my old age
you know we say well you know gonna be
dead in 20 years so who cares but I
think but my grandson is going to be 82
years old in the year 2100 you know so
even for an old guy like me I have to
think about these things do you worry I
mean are these things that raise your
hands if you think I'm crazy
[Laughter]
just checking to see that you listening
raise your head if you think that you
are actually trying to work in such a
way that will help us survive that's
pretty optimistic that's pretty good
it's okay conference closed I think
we're done given the topic of the of the
day in this room there is a selection
bias you need to ask the people who
didn't come to this particular okay
track so talk to your friends I actually
have a different question how many
people consider themselves at some level
an artist or a musician
yeah nice that's what I love to see I
mean that the idea that we're trying to
you know that we I always get it
backwards we live to work no no we work
to live right where our lives are very
rich and and there's a lot going on day
to day that's not about the workplace
and the idea that we can be moving
forward using technology to to try some
new things out and and you know all
these hands go up that's great
and so how many of you think it's silly
to make these distinctions between sort
of Arts and Sciences
that's interesting
because there used to be more of a
connection and maybe there will be more
in the future right let me try something
else on you guys do you mind if I
no no just because there's there's an
easy mind I just have a couple of things
that I want to try one of them is you
know we tried the gravity experiment
right let's take this one step further
and I'm gonna play you some it's like a
slow dance that goes to the second beat
one two three one two three and this is
to indicate when you hear something like
[Music]
this kind of a decision
and then that is not a dissonance I want
to have you guys listen three beats to
the second beat and how it relates
[Music]
okay so this is something that I think
the pianist that worked with the AI
understands the kind of very subtle
timing that is incredibly makes things
of vulnerable humanistic and meaningful
right so if you listen once again your
lines that go down and their lines that
go up so the line that goes down has the
dissonant note on the second beat the
lines that go up don't so let's hear
what's wrong
[Music]
so this is something very very simple
which you could say you know deep a I
deep learning maybe one day can create
and I wish it could but what I also wish
is that the understand that
understanding and the meaning comes from
feelings right
the feeling of gravity the feelings of
dissonance and resolution the feelings
of being weighted down the feelings of
aspirational group moving upwards in
direction with less conflict and because
those are things that we all go through
on a daily basis and all of what we do
in our work and in our love so so so
it's another way of interpreting
information you inject the humanity of
who we are into what this beautiful
piece of music that you actually had us
listened to so it's totally possible but
and I've I think that one of you know
what there was a book that came out a
number of years ago called des cartes
error right because we are and you know
that if we are all about reasoning we
would either be a much better shape or
much worse right and obviously we don't
always do what's in our best interest
except in Canada
okay so two or three things came came up
from from what you said the first
comment I hope is interesting to the to
the machine learning practitioners in
the room which is first night so when
yo-yo said the person who who coded up
this machine learning algorithm she was
classical pianist etc it's actually true
and my initial reaction to that was well
this guy doesn't understand what we do
because you know who cares as she's a
classical pianist or not this is machine
learning it's math but in fact that's
not the case at all right like the prior
at the prior knowledge that we bring to
the table when you're sweating and
you're working everyday and you're
trying something new the kinds of
intuitions that come to the table they
really influence in the work and I love
it that you got that right away and you
know that's really that's really that's
really my one bit of feedback I want to
pass that the microphone to one of you
too if you have other and and when we
talked about that I asked because you
you know you have to make decisions
while you're doing your algorithms you
have to end those decisions they come
from where they come from your emotion
they come from what you know they come
from your understanding so it's
wonderful that we have this opportunity
to you know to take a step back as
practitioners and because life is crazy
and we're working hard on making things
work there's a deadline we have to
finish that paper this code is supposed
to work okay but but what does it mean
why do I do that
how do I am I expressing myself to all
that and it's it's it's funny because
you said a great a great portion of what
we do and why maybe we're we're doing
bad things in the world is true Amazon
emotion it's not only reason for me it's
like it's evident as since again I'm
managing people I know that it's not
logic even for researchers that you know
emotion is a big part of who we
we are we work so of course this is this
is a huge a huge chunk of the code that
is in there it's it's interesting that
all the comments about that music that
you presented are about the person who
programmed the AI and not the AI itself
and here's where I want to bring an
example from indigenous perspectives so
an indigenous language is a lot of them
not all of them obvious there's a many
languages there's 11 nations just in
Quebec but some language like the Eno
and decree so they have two genders and
four so for example in French we have
feminine masculine so for example a tree
would be a knob masculine and the table
would be in table feminine but the two
genders in you know for example are
something that's animate so the tree is
animate has a soul and the table is an
animate and it doesn't have a soul and
so the question that I ask my inner
friends is well what about AI is AI I
animate or is it inanimate and I got
some very different question answers to
that so for example some of my friends
said well it depends if you interact
with that so once you interaction for
example with your Alexa she becomes
animate while if you just carry the
physical thing around its inanimate and
this question is also explored by
indigenous science fiction writers such
as drew heron Taylor that you might know
that wrote a book called take me to your
chief about efficient about robots in
general and has one story about
artificial intelligence that is coming
alive and the actual intentions itself
ask itself
what's my religion and then it goes
through different religion and says I
can be Christian a Buddhist because they
don't think I exist and they don't think
I have a soul and so I want to be
indigenous
because indigenous people think I have a
soul
and then it becomes really feeling close
and I said a question can it feel can
artificial intelligence feel and I think
a lot of you might say no but isn't that
the reason we use for so many things
which are inferior to us by saying it
cannot feel and so in this short story
the original intelligence feel so bad
about what we did to indigenous people
that it doesn't want to exist in this
world and it destroys itself and I think
those reflection are really important in
how when we build AI well that's great
that's probably a good place to end I
think do you have any final thoughts no
this is amazing definitely I want to
leave time for you if you're gonna pick
up your cello again well I don't want to
be the person they made that
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not me applaud him it's died my
brother you know what they want you I
told everybody told me in secret as I'm
coming for deathless so maybe the last
thing I want to show is that based on
what you just said that I think
sometimes one thing that appears in one
culture to mean one thing may mean
something very different in another
culture so for example you take this but
Adam in the Soviet Union in Shostakovich
his language that was about the military
right and so that's consistent in all of
his music in Bach's music it's a joy
theme so I'm going to end with
[Music]
that's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
her depressant
so I think we have just over ten minutes
I believe we have just over ten minutes
and you know this might be a good
opportunity there for valeria order for
Karina to share some of the work that
you're doing through element AI to bring
together arts etc as well as Karina's
work representing the yeah in digital
yeah very quickly and everything is on
our Facebook page so go there
importantly we have a residency for
artists there's a call for candidacy it
ends in January so what we want you want
to bring an artist in the maialex
Center with all the researchers there to
enlighten the researchers with the
presence of an artist and and use this
as a way to start conversation so go see
on our Facebook page there's a workshop
there's art gallery using a generative
design and all that and well I think we
need time for your work also so thank
you thank you I had a few images I don't
know if just very quickly because I
already shared some it with you as I was
telling you is the importance for me to
connect different systems of knowledge
between communities and Industry and
academia and I think it's important to
remember how important indigenous
perspectives are in artificial
intelligence one example I have of
indigenous languages being pertinent to
technology is this word in multitude
that's X or book and what this word
means is this feeling of anticipation
that leads you to keep looking outside
to see if anyone is coming and I think
that's how we feel about our cellphones
we keep checking them another indigenous
concept are the wampum belts so you
might know about wampum belts
so one compels use only two variables
white beads and purple beads to tell a
very complex story and record a lot of
information reminds you of something
binary and some people even credit one
pumps for the invention of hypertext so
Google it if you're interested I told
you about the difference between animate
and inanimate objects in the indigenous
languages and I already told you also
about drew head and teller and and his
novel and there also other indigenous
novelist this one is from Australia
ambolyn from Illuma and she is also
saying that it doesn't matter if AI is
human or not human because in indigenous
systems you can respect something that's
not human such as the Sun and the stars
and the wind and finally we touched on
the concept of thinking in the future
and one of the important iroquois
concept is thinking seven generations
ahead
so about 140 years but in terms of
technology
what does AI 7.0 looks like what is it
seven generation from now so that's when
we're thinking about the values and what
we're constructing we shouldn't just
think now but really in the future so
that's some time to share with you thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I think we've got time for at
least a few questions so if you are
stuck in the middle of an island raise
your hand otherwise anyone who can make
their way to a mic starting with it uh
yeah that gentleman over there thank you
thanks to all of you so I think the
biggest problem that I can see is that
we have a culture which focuses so much
on greed competition and not on harmony
mutual support and so you know it's one
thing to work towards survival it's one
thing to work towards personal
productivity or group productivity it's
even another thing to work towards
particular applications that help people
get through tough situations but there's
this fundamental substrate that we all
live in which one person told me from a
different country he said in America
you're like a bacterial culture whereas
my culture we're a connective tissue you
know where you're all cells and you're
all trying to survive but in America the
fundamental work well in the bacterial
culture case the relationship
fundamentally is competition where his
culture he thought it's the opposite and
so if that's just the baseline how do we
change that because I feel that would be
the thing that leaves everything else to
succeed with technology or anything else
so how do we change our culture to be
this just collaborative one
I think you could aren't you doing your
really interesting and knowing your
answer come on that you know one of the
things with when you don't have a steady
job is that I have to travel for a
living and one of the things that I've
been doing lately is to go into a lot of
smaller communities and wherever I go I
find people that are not in the news
that are actually helping one another
and it's it's astonishing the numbers of
people actually in in in inner cities in
rural areas small and mid-sized cities
people are actually forming communities
all the time we just don't always read
about them they don't get the voices
that that that others have they don't
have the same kind of platform but if
you guys can help identify these folk
and join them together so they don't
feel isolated and they don't feel like
their voices are not heard it becomes an
unbelievably powerful a group of people
that could move agendas and and that I
you know that's my hope for for
everybody but I do see anecdotally lots
of evidence for for that and it's not
okay in the States
yes corporate culture is a certain way
but actually in in society very often
you have different you have people
acting differently can I follow up on
that exact I'm also really hopeful about
the micro sort of the local communities
helping each other out for the first
time in my life I'm almost 50 I'm
genuinely concerned about our democracy
and our Free Press and I think it's not
just in the United States and I think we
need to be thinking about ways to
protect
our core institutions and and make sure
that they remain stable and fair and and
continue to build the kind of a almost
like a Maslow's hierarchy of needs like
there's so much basic work that we need
to do to make society better and only if
we do that and achieve that are we
really going to make any difference with
AI and machine learning I'm going to
jump in here for a moment we've got a
question from the front row hi first
thanks for the warning full of music and
comments so my question is about the
panel is about creativity at least part
of it I think with the AI creating more
more art music and other art that at
least for some people is becoming closer
and closer to what they would expect to
see from artists what your view on what
is the implication on how we think about
creativity and and and does it have an
impact on that and how how how should we
think about it I mean for me a lot of
the of what I think is art that I want
to go back to over and over again are
works of art that or that actually make
me think about things and actually have
a more concise clearer deeper
understanding of human nature than I do
or a broader understanding or of nature
so I don't think of scientists as not
artists I think people who are probing
the unknown I think are a version of
artists and if they want to try and
build something that they can bring back
that other people can build from so
again I don't want to make that
distinction of well hey I can do this
there are people behind AI
I mean I mean just saying you know and
you know the other thing to keep in mind
is that you know art artists so reliant
upon a deep understanding of culture our
culture and so you know out of whatever
Andy Warhol in some very real way
wouldn't be art if you transported it to
13th century England right so the fact
that you can just generate I argue that
the fact that you just generate is not
is not enough and so you know maybe
someday we'll have AI technology that is
embedded in our culture and understands
us and has political opinions etc but I
mean I don't think it's gonna happen in
our lifetimes
Yosi you know I think we're we're a
little I'm not trying to hurry things
along or anything like that but you know
I think we've got a we've got a lot to
address a fascinating question my
personal position around that is really
for me art is a way for human to express
something and another human to receive
that that expression so of course it
needs an understanding of the human
nature and the only thing that I'm
worried about is that because things are
get are getting so easy we have access
to easy things we can generate things
easily that we don't take the time to on
to to to just come to ourselves and
understand who we are as questions about
our human nature and we just enjoy
things that are pleasing and and that's
all so that's the the only thing that
I'm worried about you know one of the
things that I love about Montreal is
that I think people here and this is not
exclusive to Montreal it's the people
everywhere have that same trade but I
think they keep a sense of the non
measurables
in tact so in other words the inner life
is important I look at you as a human
being I don't look at you as what you do
what can you do for me what kind of
transaction can I have with you know the
people actually can talk without a
specific agenda and enjoy each other
that's something I think is so precious
we need that if we don't have that as a
toddler we won't survive you know
experiments have proven that so there's
certain things that we need as human
beings and that need to bring us into
life and to bring us out of life and
those things until we actually evolve
into something else are going to stay
with us and we have to need to deal with
it over and over and over again so the
time is currently just passed one I have
received a green light and a bit of
permission to go a bit over so what I
might propose that we do is have the
next three people just do a rapid-fire
set of questions please keep it to like
one or two sentences and not run-on
sentences alright sentence once it it's
called weather vive what you describe in
Montreal sentence - I'm not a fan of
survival survival of the fittest
I think when I think about beauty about
art I think about beauty about quality
of life I think so I think we're going
beyond survival where we're actually you
know why are we living and and what
Valerie was mentioning like connecting
with people that's that's you know but
bring jari to life in this kind of thing
so I would like just to hear your
thoughts about this philosophical
direction of going survival I think is
to American competition and we need to
survive no I mean we need to live
17:18 sentences okay okay so one is
survival number two hi my question is I
guess is a little bit more philosophical
I guess as a musician
Yoma to you do you often make music or
play music that appeals to as most
people as you can or do you do multiple
different style music I call that goes
to different groups of people and I
wonder if you you have you CAI to be
doing the same that is there such a
universal value that you I should strive
through or should I be many different
kinds of values sorry and not a mouthful
but okay cool so survival generalization
versus specification and then finally so
as this lunch I think I've heard a lot
about like equating these machines to be
more human-like to be able to generate
art but to me I think like there's no
difference between a toaster in the AI
that we're developing in terms it is
just a machine that's that's like
deterministically producing an output
based on this stuff that's already there
right so do you think there's this quest
to humanize these machines so they like
we just won't have to accept them we are
just machines thank you
does does life imitate art or does art
imitate technology our just technology
in the name I don't know good luck well
for Simone's comments about not being a
fan of survival of the fittest
luckily survival of the fittest is a fan
of you so to speak because you're alive
in this room and so that's a plus but I
agree that building on top of that in is
is this idea that we should we should
work to live in that vice-versa
Jawad aviv i think we're one giant
experiment there's you know this is what
we make of what we have of what we are
and the results will be the results of
our and our common endeavors in many
ways the more power we
the more we we deserve what we get right
because a lot of people are unfortunate
in not having access and you're working
hard to make that possible but if we do
have access then we actually we're more
than teenagers we have to actually then
construct our living styles and in a way
that is most conducive to our
surroundings and the more we know in a
way sadly the more responsibility we
have and I think I worry that the the
our speed of acquiring knowledge
outpaces our ability to absorb and to
integrate it into our lives and I think
if I can help in that way and to
actually help us see the you know the
largest so one principle in in art in
storytelling is that you have to
actually have two things happening in
your mind at the same time the universal
and the most specific so the biggest
story as well as the most immediate
moment and I think that's true with the
deeper you go into something the more
you find the universal so it's not about
AI or art it's about how deeply you go
into because you go so deeply into AI
you get into philosophy you get into
spirituality you get into asking the why
questions right and if I'm a technician
I'll just deliver something to you but
if I want to say something something
more I'll have to actually dig deeper so
to your question of what to play it's
really who are you sharing it with you
know you don't offer a meal of anything
to a guest that's coming to your house
you try and figure out who's coming to
your house
so if I'm playing a piece of music to
you I am you're in my house
so you're my guest so I have to care
about you and I'm not you're not a
stranger we're we're already
establishing a relationship and in
culture it's not a business plan in
culture you make a relationship you
never break it because if you break it
it's not real so that's a great
responsibility it's like a parent you
know you don't say well today you're not
my child because I don't like you well
maybe add something about the question
about survival I think once again it's
how do we find survival is it survival
of the fittest
or is it survival of everyone together
or is and what does it mean to be alive
you know is it about spiritual survival
and survival all those parts of us that
are not only function in this physical
world so I think it goes back into this
interaction with AI teaching us about
ourselves and thinking about what does
it mean to be human it was it does it
mean to be alive I'm gonna just add
something on that on that note because
what I find fascinating is the question
that the the artistic world brings to
the I community are exactly that okay
they are seeing the AI trying to imitate
what they do and now they are asking
okay who are we and it's it's wonderful
so thanks a lot I think I'll just end
with one thing which is that I think I
still don't know the answer of what
makes us human I think that's the that's
the question we have to ask because I'm
not sure we understand ourselves yet and
just think in the last couple years you
know the gut and the brain the two
brains so suddenly a week in control of
our will the
my stomach tells me I want to eat
something and before I even know it
right I mean this is one thing we've
just discovered another organ between
our our skin that is actually that we
have not discovered because usually when
we cut through we don't see there's so
many things we don't know about us and
in the field of neuroscience we are
really discovering many many things so
of which I becomes a you know one part
of what humans do so until we understand
who we are it's very hard to be in
control so that comes back to all of the
basic questions that actually will
remain unanswered but we have to be able
to live with that that seems like a good
ending point lives with that yeah
live with that
[Applause]
[Music]
babysitter I certainly couldn't think of
a better ending you know the big
question of AI being what makes us human
and I wish we could continue talking
here but yo-yo has two more stops this
is the first of three during his day of
action here in Montreal Hill after
having performed the six Bach's cello
suite pieces last night in what I heard
was a fantastic performance at 2:00 p.m.
he'll be in the Metro playing the global
human residence and music and machine
this is our name of the thing and then
at 4:00 p.m. in indigenous futures in
media over at Whitehall studio whitewall
studio excuse me so we've got to head
out but again I'd like to thank all of
you for joining us this afternoon and
can we please give another round of
applause to everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
represent
[Applause]